what's going on guys we have got a super
cool treat for you today so you know
screen junkies makes honest trailers
but it's rare that we get the creators
or directors of one of the films we do
an honest trailer about to come in and
talk about it well that's what's going
down today we have the directors of
Captain America Civil War and the honest
trailer we're gonna talk about today
Captain America Winter Soldier the Russo
brothers fellas thank you so much for
being here thanks for having us in and
the people who made the honest trailer
are not going to get out of here
unscathed
you're gonna have to sit here and watch
these men who sweated it out making a
feature film call you out on your little
shenanigan dan Merle writer editor and
Spencer Gilbert one of the writer of
honest trailers so fellas Anthony Joe so
there's a story floating around that you
had talked about honest trailer proofing
your movie we did it was a big phrase
that I would use when we were working on
the script in the writers room typically
Anthony and Marcus McFeely who wrote
Winter Soldier and wrote civil warrant
or writing infinity war we get together
with the producer
Nate Moore and we would go through the
script together and if there are any
sort of laughs and logic you know it was
always my phrase like I'm not gonna
[ __ ] let honest trailers beat us up
over this last night so we're gonna fix
this story point you would be surprised
how much the idea caught on though and
how frequently we use the phrase honest
trailer proof months and months that's
amazing how does that feel you guys well
it feels great to hear but now I feel
like a kid called into the principal's
office well um I think without further
ado what do you say we watch it all
together and feel free to stop it call
us out give us a little a little story
any notes yeah if you like if you want
to punch up any of their jokes also feel
we've got a few suggestions awesome
without further adieu okay I have an
issue with this yeah oh you weren't that
impressed with his first movie he wasn't
your favorite Avenger now get ready for
the sequel that made everyone say holy
Sh who knew Captain America kicked so
much ass
okay let's pause there for a second
America yeah I was a big comic book
collector as a kid cap was not a
favorite character of mine growing up
the issue I had with cap as a character
was is that I found a very square so our
whole approach with the movie was how
can we make cap interesting to a comic
book fan like myself who didn't love the
character the first movie first Avenger
was very much a love letter to the
Golden Age of the character which is
great way to introduce him but we
thought okay now that he's gone away for
70 years and he's coming back to the
modern world here's an opportunity for
the guy he can be somebody different he
can decide he wants to join the modern
world the captain is back and he didn't
skip leg day this is you know he's a
super soldier yeah and he's got a
frisbee you know you are kind of limited
in your expression on an action level of
him as a character which which in turn
as a director then you know puts us in a
position where we go okay well you know
maybe we have to up the volume of
ass-kicking because we can't can't vary
up the style of it dramatically and
which is why he kicks a lot of people
yeah literally kicks ass yeah I have to
say watching the movie the first time
that moment and it's coming up in this
one when he kicks the guy over the boat
that was the woman in my head I was like
okay this is different this is gonna be
a different cap okay I'm on it yes
phrase you used is is like literally
what we would use when we would talk to
the stunt team or to the producers and
in terms of why we wanted that sequence
in the movie is like we want we want
this sequence to announce that to the
audience that this is a different cast
at America that's literally how our
headlight our title of the sequence is
when he's not kicking ass
name's vocab as he spends his free time
and freaking out kids at museos that's
our attendance queue
oh yeah and catching up at last 60 years
of pop culture I'll put it on the list
man stole a lot of discussion about the
site you know we like you know we worked
on shows like a rest development
community we like Easter egg in things
we like being a self-referential that's
why we we did put Star Wars on the list
because we thought it was funny that Sam
Jackson appears in both universes we
often referred to that device that he
used in when the cars flipped over the
winter soldiers coming after him and he
cuts a hole in the the concrete to
escape as his lightsaber yeah we're
going to do for the the bloopers reel we
were actually just gonna turn it into a
lightsaber when you hit the button ah
yeah that's kind of laying on the ground
and he goes in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is just a coincidence that
makes window window looks like like Last
Action Hero where it's just so much just
the wall and plays all the
Schwarzenegger part in my brain when
Hydra returns cap needs to take him out
by forming a team he can trust including
Black Widow a sneaky double agent we
really shouldn't trust and felt good
don't trust with them in the movies yeah
Black Widow question were you trying to
set up a widow cap romance or like a or
maybe a different romance than they went
within Ultron we always know we always
thought of it as like a work wife work
husband relationship so you know there
was an intimacy to it in our minds
always but it was it was never
necessarily such we thought if it got
romance he could be predictable you know
we've got to be more interesting if we
kept them platonic but develops like a
deep brother-sister kind of relationship
between the two of them where you know a
cap as a guy with a code and and her as
a double agent who who never has a code
are forced to trust each other and work
with each other yeah so he's moving up
our hands and say the movies one you
have to be honest it's good but since
honest trailers is it
a series get ready for med baking
prepare for the shocking revelation that
Hydra has been secretly growing inside
of shield all along despite the fact
that the previous Marvel movies really
didn't do anything to set that every
epoch is like a subtle variation on how
didn't they know Hydra was also do you
really have to set it up do you
I mean Hydra was really biding their
time very they they stayed quiet through
a lot of ups and downs for shield and
then now is the moment a lot of people
collecting on a heart attack and over
the years a lot of secret deaths inside
the organization and at the end of the
day the plan was to just was to shoot
everyone from the sky if I remember
correctly the plan is to gain control of
this powerful secret weapon and
potentially dangerous - yeah - aren't
you guys scared of future we will bow to
our robot overlords yes
Evon must calls face - yes yes doesn't
keep you up at night
a little bit yeah so I'll ignore
questions like when did they fury stop
wearing the bulletproof vest that saved
his life in the Avengers why didn't oh
nice cape is about hi gang so there yeah
Nick Fury was if you recall when he got
jumped by the by it by the Winter
Soldier and his team he was just driving
home from work true you know he wasn't
going thinking about dinner obtain a
tesseract I'm just gonna pick up a
burger and uh
Netflix exactly oh nice another
University
why didn't Oni stork find out about
hydra when he decrypted all of shields
files how did an agency that employs
hydra was bearing all the files so deep
they even available double secret
encryption double incredible how did an
agency that employs thousands of people
hide the fact that half of its agents
were members of a secret Nazi death cult
for over 60 years if some have had their
hands on the tesseract for so long all
right we're gonna address each net pack
even though it's probably were you with
it technically half of shield portion
Encino do you think roughly yeah and
there's probably Department specific
like more the arms guys than the IT
staff yes there you go we are some minds
which you know you can't trace this in
the storytelling but it's like you know
there were people strike position rumlow
exactly that could that could steer
other members into the right positions
etc or whatever how many hikers were in
HR do we do say specifically in the
movie that that strike and the
Helicarrier crews had been infiltrated
so it really done a targeted takeover of
big word is takeover there's like 100
guy in the mailroom just switching out
people's so sit back and enjoy the best
standalone Marvel movie since Iron Man
full of awesome action awesome cameos
and one awesome twist they run into the
ground where Bucky turns out to still be
alive this is your advance over campus
this might even be a little more than an
inch on this is a Marvel general
critique is that no impacts to killing
people in the Marvel yet
yeah yeah in comic books nobody ever
dies in comedy it's a comic book
convention you know there's an it's a
very you know it's an upside and a
downside if you kill somebody you
destroy like you know people's hopes of
future stories obviously everyone you
never kill somebody you sort of lose the
dramatic impact there in those days so
it's a lose-lose story Austin Powers war
unfrozen case yeah it's the safety of
the free world on two people not wanting
to buy gum now in fairness he knew he
was going to be back within a few hours
okay so if there was you know you make
choices
what was the bidding war like between
the bubblicious people in the juicer
from somebody at my role they can tell
you that I bet that's like an anti
product placement cuz no one wants it
right I have some bubblicious how the
deal got struck I have six years where
the room so what was it what's it like
sitting here with these gentlemen they
they watched your work they commented on
it well it's a lot less painless than
Thor hammer Thor a little bit and Zak
guzik was a he hammered right back
yeah pun intended did he do his homework
before he came in he like studied it was
like a French thing yeah just do it yeah
yeah but man it's an honor and a
privilege and it adds an undue amount of
pressure when you're at the next one so
Thanks definitely have to do it for
civil warrants yeah for sure gentlemen
Anthony Joe your street cred went up
big-time for coming in here and watching
the honest trailer and commenting on it
thanks for making a great movie and yeah
it's been a pleasure let me tell you
that it's a total joy for us I mean we
get such a kick out of this it's a lot
of fun and we love what you do so we're
happy to be here and just keep doing it
and give give a civil war your best
effort yeah we are we're the film fans
and we've seen just about every honest
trailer we basta what we do enjoy poking
holes and movies the same way you do so
very cool thank you awesome Dan Spencer
thanks for coming across the hall and
doing this thank you for watching what
we leave out let us know in the comments
section below and what was your favorite
part
what would you have nitpicked tell us in
the comments below
again I'm how run dick hit me up on
Twitter bye bye hey screen junkies don't
turn that dial be sure to check out the
epic extra video with a Russo brothers
where they'd wrap their own MCU fantasy
tees and answer your questions about
Captain America Civil War it's Russo
versus Russo in this epic director
battle who will win click on the box or
in the description below to find out